[Music]
welcome to the unboxing
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is the one we've been waiting for this
is the one i told you to skip iphone 8
for this is the one that represents the
future of apple's smartphones this is
iphone 10 and while it doesn't say x
anywhere on the front of the box uh
people are pretty much always going to
call this one the x i've just accepted
that
so this is your first look at the
unboxing experience and spoiler it's
pretty much exactly the same as iphone 8
was and almost every other iphone
headphones adapters stickers it's all in
the box but i guess it's a good thing
there's no surprises here so you can see
right here off the bat it's a really
shiny chromy reflective phone uh this is
the silver one and you can see how shiny
the sides are the space gray one though
is a bit more toned down and so the only
thing that was actually new during the
setup of iphone 10 is now you set up
face id during first boot instead of the
fingerprint touch id but yeah this is
brand new and it's been a couple weeks
since we last saw this phone at that
apple event so seeing it again for the
second time is kind of a reminder of all
the things that are new about this thing
obviously the biggest difference is the
display up front the 5.8 inch oled
corner to corner screen that fits in a
footprint smaller than the iphone 8 plus
which has a smaller screen so naturally
pretty much all the focus is going to be
on that and the notch at the top and how
apps handle it etc and i can tell you
that aside from all the incompatible
apps i've come across that are going to
have to get updated my experience with
the display panel itself have been
pretty decent so far it's bright it's
contrasty well calibrated definitely not
over saturated like some oleds can be
and just handling and playing with this
phone in the studio here for the first
time it's answered some immediate
questions that i had about it from the
last video so first of all since there's
no home button obviously you have that
swipe up gesture to go home but we were
wondering how do you take a screenshot
that is power and volume up so that's
the new screenshot combo for iphone 10.
and then since holding the power button
now goes to siri how do you turn the
phone off while it's going to be long
pressing the power button and volume up
key and that'll get you to see that
power off menu so those are two new key
combos to memorize there and then of
course i was reminded of how many
gestures there are now to memorize
obviously when you get rid of a button
there's a whole bunch of swiping and
gestures to replace it so there's a
multitasking and app switching motions
which are pretty similar but both kind
of useful in their own way
depending on how you use the phone
really that's on top of the screenshot
and power off combos plus long holding
the power button for siri and double
pressing it for apple pay but basically
there's a lot going on and if you're
gonna make a phone that's all screen
obviously you have to be able to do it
all without a lot of buttons anyway one
of the biggest differences between
iphone 8 and iphone 10 is the new
front-facing camera suite up at the top
in that notch the ir blaster the depth
sensor etc and all that enables a couple
of new things with this phone number one
is obviously face id
the setup like you saw was pretty quick
and painless and it's been working
pretty well since then for unlocking my
phone now i've only really had this
phone for a day like the rest of press
but so far in this time it's been fine
and it works as advertised as far as
being smart and not easily spoofed you
can see the little lock under the time
when the phone is locked and basically
instead of placing your fingerprint the
phone will not unlock until you look at
the phone like you did during the setup
process and then once you do it's pretty
quick to unlock you can see the little
thing open and then you can swipe up to
open your phone and sure enough it
doesn't work with a picture of you it
doesn't work when you're looking away it
doesn't work when your eyes are closed
it just basically waits until it sees
what it saw during that setup process
and then it's good to go so no your girl
can't unlock your phone while you're
asleep with your eyes closed for those
of you who are wondering that i do have
some further thoughts on this face id
versus touch id though so stay tuned for
that in an upcoming video and i do want
to see if i can fool it with identical
twins maybe just out of curiosity anyway
with the new notch you also get a new
front-facing camera complete with selfie
portrait mode messing around with it it
seems pretty average uh interestingly
enough that pixel 2 that i've been
testing seemed way more like confident
with the front-facing camera portraits
than the iphone 10. now there's no doubt
both of these will get better with time
and software updates but just from
turning on portrait mode switching the
front-facing camera and snapping a
picture these are the types of results
you're gonna get there's a pretty big
difference between the two if you ask me
especially if you're looking at edges
and hair
and things like that and sometimes the
iphone just didn't want to blur the
background at all just got really picky
about the lighting but that's something
again we'll be testing a lot more for
the full review of this phone oh yeah
and the new front-facing camera suite
will get you
animojis so yeah you can see in these
animojis the physics of things moving
around
is actually pretty on point uh so if
you're into it you can you can map your
face to a cartoon animal head and send
it to someone an imessage
but you still can't edit tweets though
so overall there's a lot to test with
the iphone 10 now that i have it in my
hands finally as a matter of fact
definitely leave your thoughts right
below that like button with things you
want to see in the full review most
likely things like battery life camera
quality
app performance all that good stuff but
don't let me miss anything but until
then definitely get subscribed for the
upcoming videos on the channel
thanks for watching
and i'll talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]